hello
and welcome to lecture two overview and
examples
so we describe in this section the
general ideas and methods used in
machine learning
at a high level we're going to go over
all of these topics again in much more
detail later in the
course so really don't worry if some of
this seems abstract at this point or if
there are terms that you don't know
we're going to go over the mathematics
of it we're going to make precise all of
the details and
put it spell it all out both in
mathematics and in code so that you'll
be able to
know exactly what the details are in
this section we're just going to
describe
in words the principles of machine
learning some of the ideas
and some of the methods so at a high
level the main idea of artificial
intelligence is that you would like a
computer to perform a very complicated
task
something such as medical diagnosis in
here
we can imagine that we have a patient
who has a medical history
a bunch of symptoms a bunch of test
results
and a bunch of data that properties of
the patient
their height their mass their gender
and so on and we give all this
information to
a computer in some format and
we'd like the computer to come back and
say what's wrong with the patient is
this we can think about two approaches
by which you might write such a program
one is called the knowledge based
approach we
write a program where we encode in the
logic of the program
the property is the world and what they
mean so for example we would say
something like if
the patient is of this age into this
gender
and is a smoker and has this range of
blood pressure
then and so on and so on and so on
these kinds of programs can work
very well
they usually take extensive development
by experts in in this case medicine or
whatever the domain of expertise
whatever the domain of specialty is
we're applying
the program to and
uh and it takes many years of work to
achieve a working system that
has flexibility enough to handle the
sort of cases one
would like it to machine learning is
very
different in its approach instead of
humans encoding the properties of the
world
in the program in machine learning
we supply the program with historical
data
that historical data consists of a large
number of patient records
and for each one of those records we
supply all of the medical information
the test results and so on
and we may supply also diagnoses given
by a medical professional
from all of that data the machine
learning algorithm
develops a predictor it develops
the ability to make predictions and it
uses that
predictor to extrapolate so that when
it's given
a new set of patient data it can figure
out
what the diagnosis should be for that
new patient
this class is about machine learning
it's about the second of those two types
so when we think about the task of
machine learning we divide up the
process into two
generic tasks the first of those tasks
is to build a model from the data
we have to take the data and convert the
data into a format
which is easy for the computer to
understand
some of that data is rather easy to
convert for example the height is simply
a real number
some of the data maybe we may want to do
something more sophisticated with it
for example if we have an x-ray image of
a patient's arm
we could simply give the machine
learning algorithm
the image the pixel data corresponding
to that image
or we could encode that image describe
additional features of that image in an
automated way
we could for example describe the
center of mass the position of the
center of mass
of the bone we could describe
for example the uh
length and the width of various parts
of the image a whole bunch of things we
could describe which we would
have to figure out how to what we would
choose that would be informative
features of that data
in this class there are essentially two
things that we will do we will spend
some time
discussing how to
construct sensible features for many
standard classes of data
and then we will switch into a different
approach
where we discuss how to automatically
generate features from data
and it turns out that automatically
generating features can be extremely
powerful and that's one of the
key benefits of methods such as neural
networks
the second part of generating a model is
to figure out what class of models we
would like to have
there are very simple model forms that
you've probably seen before
one such model might be fit a straight
line to the data
the sort of thing you would do with
linear regression
there we would need to describe the
the slope of the line and the intercept
of the line and that's essentially two
numbers used to describe the model
those would be parameter values that
parameterize that model
alternatively we might describe the
model in a much more complicated way
we might describe the model as a tree
you might describe the model
as a neural network with weights and
activation functions these are all
different types of models
they all have parameterizations in terms
of numbers
and we would specify both the model form
and what parameters are necessary
those three things constructing mapping
the data to features
choosing the model form and choosing the
parameter values in the model
those are the those comprise the first
task in machine learning building the
model
the second task that comes up in machine
learning is testing the model or
validating the model proving that it
works
the key thing one has to do in order to
do that is test the model on
data that it didn't learn from when we
made the model we don't want to test the
model against data that we've already
used to generate the model because
that's
cheating we'll see
in more detail exactly how one goes
about testing the model
to avoid this kind of cheating and
what kind of tests one can do in order
to
uh given get an effective analysis
of whether or not we've done a good job
with our modeling
and at our prediction one of the things
one might reasonably expect is that
the process of building the model and
testing the model is
iterative if we test the model and we
find out that
the model doesn't work the predictions
that it's making are not very good
we need a way to update the model
and that's again something that we're
going to talk about later in the class
i've used the term model on this slide
extensively and i haven't really said
what model is
a model can mean several different
things one of the things it is is simply
a it's a predictor it's a function that
takes
input data and gives you a predicted
output value
it takes the set of symptoms of the
patient
and gives you a predicted diagnosis
but there are other things that could
also be a model might be a probability
distribution
it gives you a distribution over sets of
patient records to describe which ones
are likely to occur and which ones are
not likely to occur
and we'll see other things that a moral
can be as well
there's a taxonomy of machine learning
models that
is runs throughout the class and is
really how
most machine machine learning algorithms
are
categorized the key categorization
is that they're supervised models and
there's unsupervised models
so in supervised learning what we do is
we're
given some data and
we learn from it how to predict
something
and this is a one way to think about
this is as a prediction model
within the category of supervised
learning there are
two subcategories and they are
regression and classification
the only difference between those two is
in regression the quantity that's being
predicted
is a real number or a real
vector in classification the quantity
that's being predicted
lies in a finite set might be true or
false
it might be one of ten different
possible diseases
it might be one of 50 different animals
the other major category of models is
unsupervised learning models and here
the objective is not prediction but
simply to create a model of the data
so unsupervised models just create a
model of the data
they don't try to predict anything but
instead they give you the
capability to tell whether or not an
additional data record really belongs in
the same category
as all the existing records that have
been seen
they also give you the capability of
generating
new examples generating synthetic
data records that look like real data
records
for example one might make a data model
that
has learned all of the paintings of
van gogh and then we would ask such a
data model
please generate a new painting that
looks like
van gogh might have painted it
and these kinds of things are quite
possible
with modern machine learning techniques
for supervised learning
we can use we can make two different
kinds of predictions
we can either make what's called a point
estimate where we predict a value
we say given all this data that looks
like
an elephant or that looks like a dog
or we give a probabilistic answer we say
given all this data probability is
twenty percent
that's a dog and eighty percent it's an
elephant of course if you've got a
probabilistic estimate you might then
use it in order to construct a point
estimate
you might say well if the probability is
greater than fifty percent
i'm going to decide that it's an
elephant rather than a dog
one of the advantages of a probabilistic
model of course is that it's more
informative
and as a result you can make decisions
that take into account your own
tolerance of risk
these are broad categories it's a broad
taxonomy of models
there are many other categories of
models many other types of machine
learning
some of which we'll touch on or see in
examples in the class
and there are also things that don't
really fit in any one of these
categories
things which are between two categories
and we'll see some of those as well
let's think about some examples here are
some models and we can think about what
kind of models each one of these
particular
domains would require so
for example we have the
last 10 days of rainfall data
and we know the date so we know what
time of year it is
and we need to predict tomorrow's
rainfall
so how might we go about predicting
tomorrow's rainfall
we might collect data from the last 10
years
and we might divide that data into 11
day
chunks the first 10 days we would
use as data
to index the record and the last day
would be data that the machine learning
algorithm would try to
learn as a function of the previous 10
days
given many such 11 day long examples
we would hope that the machine learning
algorithm would be able to develop
a way of mapping the previous 10 days to
the next day
of course what it's predicting there is
an amount of rain
it's predicting a number
and then so this would come under the
category of supervised learning
because it's been predicting a number it
would come under the category
of regression here's another example
determined from a photo of her face if
the user
is who she claims to be
what's the data that we're learning from
we've got
a bunch of data which is
a bunch of different images of people's
faces
and associated with each one of those
we have a name now we give the
machine learning predictor a new photo
and it has to find in all of those
faces that it's seen before
is this face one of those spaces
and that would enable it to put a name
to a face
so again this is supervised learning
this is not regression this is
classification
because there's only a finite number of
possible people
that the user could be here's another
example estimate the probability
of 10 possible diagnoses given some
patient data
and test results
again this is classification we're
trying to
figure out one of ten possible answers
and we're given data
and test results so this is supervised
learning it's classification
here's a different example we'd like to
cluster customers
into 22 different groups with similar
buying habits
now this is interesting because we don't
have
an idea of what possible buying habits
are what we have is for each customer
a list of what they bought but
just describing somebody's buying habits
as a list
of what they bought that could be
anything if we think about all the
different
products that a store might sell one
person buys a particular subset of them
another person buys a different subset
of them
two people might not have apparently
much in common
and so we have to figure out
well what makes lists
of products similar
is the right way to think about
customers as
some customers are really into breakfast
cereal
and others are really into bread
or is it more natural to think about
customers
as some customers like sweet things and
some customers like savory things
or maybe some customers like red things
and some customers like green things
here we're starting to see that these
are features that are features of the
model
that we would like our machine learning
algorithm to tell us
because we don't know what they are
ourselves this is unsupervised learning
it's constructing a model which
describes
all of the customers and that model has
a structure
which allows us to put it into groups
and it allows and the machine learning
algorithm itself
tells us what the natural groupings are
here's another example estimate the risk
of an
automobile accident at a location given
the hour given the weather
this is supervised learning we have a
whole bunch of historical data about
automobile accidents at that location in
different weather conditions at
different times of day
and this is a probabilistic estimate
that we're getting rather than a point
estimate
another example is an anomaly detector
it rates how suspicious
some data is the sort of thing we'd like
to do with this
so is for example look at network
traffic
does this network traffic indicate that
somebody's trying to hack into our
network
or is it just somebody busy downloading
some
standard cat video
this is again unsupervised learning
we build a model for data
and we see okay
most of the data we see looks like this
and then if we get a new piece of data
it's an anomaly if it doesn't look like
the data we've already seen
that's what we mean by an anomaly the
last example is build a simulator that
generates
fake new data that looks like the given
data again this is unsupervised learning
this is
van gogh we've shown the machine
learning algorithm a whole bunch of
paintings and it's painting a new one
of course this has very specific
applications beyond simply making nice
pictures for us
so for example you'd like to
make cars that can drive themselves
one of the problems with that is that it
takes an awful lot of testing
and so if you have a way of generating
a simulation of driving
down the road then you can use that to
test your machine learning algorithm
your machine learning algorithm that
drives the car
can be tested by another machine
learning algorithm
that generates fake road scenarios
that look like real road scenarios so
let's turn now to how we might
measure the performance of a model
this is the topic of performance metrics
so for example if we're
having a model if we have a model which
is predicting a real number
this is supervised learning this is
regression
then we might measure how far that real
number is
from the true real number if we're
trying
to predict the amount of rainfall
then we might predict five centimeters
and
the real amount of rainfall when it when
it actually happens may turn out to be
three and a half
and so we might take the mean square
error in the amount of rainfall that we
predicted
we'd like to keep that small that would
be a very reasonable
quantity of course it's square
which means that
both positive errors and negative errors
are counted and if we just took the mean
prediction error then if we had an equal
amount of positive errors
and negative errors then it might look
like we've got very small areas so we
take mean
square very often we take rms
root mean square prediction error so
that
that's measured in the same units as the
error itself
and of course rms is a very nice error
it has lots of nice physical
correspondences to things that we know
such as
energy and sometimes that's relevant
for classification we're trying to
predict something which is
only has one only has a few different
possible outcomes
so if we're trying to tell the
difference between dogs and cats and
images
we could measure the error rate how
often we're wrong or how often we're
right
we could try and minimize how often
we're wrong
another example if we have probabilistic
models
is to say well a probabilistic model
is a model that gives us the probability
of different possible outcomes it gives
us a probability distribution
for those of you who've taken
probability before you'll know that one
of the things you're interested
in about probability distributions is
the thing called the likelihood and the
log
of the likelihood in particular that's a
way of measuring how
likely it was that the data that you saw
could have actually been generated by
the probability model that you claim
generates it
we're going to say much more about that
in a few weeks
again don't worry about it right now if
you've not heard of likelihood
so some examples you might have a
predictor that predicts tomorrow's
maximum temperature and the way you
might measure its
performance is by rms error and if the
rms air is 1.3 degrees centigrade
you may or may not be happy with that
um you might have a classifier that
predicts the topic of a newspaper
article
from a set of 50 choices with an error
rate of 5 percent
so when we do machine learning we're
always doing machine learning from data
um usually we'd like as much data as
possible
um and we also have in mind that we need
to test
the machine learning model the predictor
against data that we've never seen
before
and so the standard way of doing this is
that when one collects a whole bunch of
data from experiments or from
the field one cuts it into two parts
and puts one part aside never looks at
that part
the first part of the data we use to
train the model
we use it to develop the predictor
and once we've developed the predictor
and we've taken it to the point where
we're happy with the predict and we
think it's going to work well
we tested on this reserved piece of data
this
validation data set
to see how well it did on model on data
that was never seen before
the data that one keeps aside is called
the test set or the validation set
so now we have two performance metrics
we have how well did it perform on the
training set
and how well does it perform on a test
set
sometimes one can develop a model that
performs really well on the training set
but
very poorly on the test set
an easy way of doing this is that if
you're trying to tell
a trainer system to tell the difference
between dogs
and cats it could just remember all of
the images that it's seen
and tell you oh that's one you told me
was a cat and that's when you told me it
was a dog
and it doesn't help it at all when it
sees a new image that
isn't any of the images it's seen before
in general if you've got a model that
does well on the training set but poorly
on the test set
you say it's over fit it's learned
properties of the training data that
are specific to that particular data set
rather than general properties of the
underlying phenomena that you're trying
to learn
on the other hand if you've you've
developed a model using the test set and
it works on the training set
well then you might say well it worked
on that data which it never seen before
maybe it will work on some other data
too
that it's never seen before so there is
there are
a number of different ways one might
choose a model
one of the common methods is to say well
i'm going to choose a class of models
i'm going to choose a model structure
or perhaps a form of model of a type of
model i'm going to say i'm only
interested in models which are linear
regression models so i'm only interested
in models
which are convolutional neural networks
or i'm only
interested in models that are trees
those models are described by numbers by
parameters
what you do is you say okay well i'm
going to define a loss function
a figure of merit which tells me how
well the model performs on one single
data point
it might be for example the square of
the error
between the predicted amount of rainfall
and the actual amount of rainfall
and then we're going to choose the
parameter values that enter into the
model
by varying them and finding the ones
that minimize
the average loss over all of the
training data
this is a very general scheme and it's
extremely widely
used in machine learning and it's called
empirical
risk minimization
and you can use this to fit all sorts of
models all of the models that we've
talked about so far in this section
can be fit using empirical risk
minimization
let's look at this diagnosis example
here the goal is to predict if a patient
has a disease
based on whether or not he or she
exhibits
10 symptoms
what the historical data consists of is
a large number of patient records
each record contains 10 booleans
specifying the presence or absence of
the 10 symptoms
and it contains an additional boolean
that specifies
whether that particular patient
had that particular disease
we have a very large number of these
records
each record has 11 booleans
the machine learning algorithm
ingests that data it learns for a while
and then it comes out with a predictor
what that predictor does for us is we
take that predictor
and then we give it 10 new booleans
corresponding to some other patient who
would like to know whether or not they
have that particular disease
and it returns for us a single boolean
which is the prediction of whether or
not that
patient has the disease
this is supervised learning this is a
classifier
we're predicting an outcome that takes
only two possible values
and we're going to judge the model by
its error rate
because it can only give a true or false
answer
and we'll do that by having a separate
set of test data
a separate collection of 11 booleans
which we didn't use to generate the
model
of course a probabilistic model would
return a probability that the patient
had
the disease and not just a boolean
and we might immediately think about how
to make this more sophisticated
we wouldn't just give it 10
booleans describing symptoms we'd also
give it
other patient data test results
demographic facts
information about where
the patient lives what the patient's
habits are
all sorts of things
and you might give it random stuff
patient's favorite color patient shoe
size
patient's favorite movies
because you don't necessarily know
what's going to make the predictions
better
what you'd hope is that your machine
learning algorithm could distinguish for
you what's meaningful and what's not
and we will see that machine learning
algorithms can in fact do that
it can tell you that that data was
totally uninformative
now here's another example this is a
classic example
this is called the imnist
mnist dataset
it's a collection of 60 000 images
and these are all hand written digits
you can see in these images there's
quite a lot of variation in
the way different people right
the same digit
our prediction algorithm would take all
of these 60 000
images and learn
a classifier it would give us back
a prediction given a new 28 by 28 pixel
image
it would give us back a prediction as to
what digit
was in that image so this is a very well
used
[Music]
training set test set data set
it's it's considered easy by modern
standards you can do very well
with very simple
algorithms and we will learn
how to do that in this class
uh it's worth talking a little bit about
data um
uh because machine learning is such
a a widely used
discipline
at the moment there's been a huge amount
of effort to collect
data partly to
partly by the research community and
industry
to develop better machine learning
algorithms
and partly because people are trying to
apply machine learning in very specific
disciplines
in order to develop useful products
useful tools
so one of them is is a thing called
kaggle kaggle is a website
it began as a startup it was acquired by
google a few years ago
and what they do is they collect data
data sets
and they run competitions to
[Music]
see how well people can develop
predictors and they do the job of
holding validation sets in escrow
so that people can't cheat and you can
sign up for kaggle
just give them your email address
they'll you can download the data set
you can see how well you can do it doing
prediction
on the tech on the training set and then
you can submit your predictor to them
to see how well you do on the validation
set and compare your performance against
the best the state of the art
so kaggle has many different data sets
we will uh
in this class we'll set homework quite a
few of the data sets will come from
kaggle
and uh it's a very useful tool for
for learning and for developing uh
machining algorithms
uh imagenet dataset is
a very popular dataset contains 14
million
images of a variety of different things
and in many different categories and
[Music]
it's used for classification
street view google street view has a
whole bunch of house number images 600
images of digits this is much harder
than the mnist data set because these
are all photographs
of the numbers on the front of houses
and
you're probably aware that those things
come in all sorts of strange formats
curly letters
strange-shaped tiled images pretty
colors
all sorts of strange borders around them
and so
identifying those kinds of images it's
much less structured much less clean
data one has to work with anyone can
still do very well with the methods that
we'll show you in this class
as you know many people are working on
self-driving cars
we're fortunate in that lift has
uh open sourced uh some of their data
and uh that's a source of data that one
can use to develop a
very specific very focused algorithms
for
perception for self-driving cars and in
particular there's
one would like to identify the sorts of
things one sees on the road
pedestrians bicycles other cars
trucks road signs traffic
lights these kinds of things
that data is interesting because it
doesn't only consist of
images and not even single images but it
consists
of multiple different
sensors observing the same thing
so you have on a on a lift self driving
car i think you have six cameras and
three lidars and so the lidar images
give you a
range range measurements uh as pixel
data
and of course cameras give you color
measurements as pixel data
and so one can develop
machine learning algorithms that use
both types of data simultaneously
one can also develop machine learning
algorithms that take advantage
of the fact that the image one sees now
has something to do with the image one
sees
a tenth of a second from now as the car
moves down the road
and so there's a lot of scope there for
developing things that are
very much subjects of current research
but also very likely to be
used in practice and there are many
other large data sets online now
and a simple
like any topic that's on your mind you
can google for data sets and there are
there's been a because of the search and
interest in machine learning many data
sets have become
public and so one has data which
would previously have been hard to get
and held by
specific companies that kept their data
private
now those data sets are being made
public because everybody benefits if we
develop better algorithms to understand
such data
i should say a word about software
much effort has gone into developing
machine learning software
these here i list torch keras thiano
tensorflow psychic learn spark
ml lib flux these are all different
packages
for doing machine learning um
they're they're in all different
languages they're in r matlab python
java
julia we're going to be using flux in
julia
many of these packages support gpu
acceleration that's useful because
it turns out that when you're trying to
learn
uh image classifiers for example that
uses quite a lot of processing power
and so if you can you can gain a lot of
benefit and reduced
training time if you've got uh using if
you're using a package
that can take advantage of gpu
acceleration such as flux
also many of these packages will allow
you to
run training on the cloud
so if you don't have a very powerful
computer at home you can run
training on the cloud
and but as you'll see in this class the
even though there are these complicated
packages very extensive software
packages in fact
you can write the software to do machine
learning yourself
we will show you how to do it and so
that if you wanted to you could write
everything
yourself from scratch
we don't recommend you do so lots of
time has gone into making these packages
fast and
code you might will probably not be that
fast
in fact the general philosophy of this
class is to have you write as little
code as possible
the class is really about how machine
learning works
how to use
these tools how to formulate machine
learning program
problems how to think about machine
learning problems how to
how to appropriately featurize data sets
how to think about what type what types
of model one should use
it's much more about those things than
it is about how to
effectively implement the algorithms we
will teach you how to effectively
implement the algorithms
but really the purpose of that is to
demystify
the way these packages work rather than
so that
you should go and do it yourself
you